madame la ministre mes chers collègues
effectivement depuis plusieurs mois la
tension monte entre l'iran et les états
unis discours défiant la communauté
internationale violation des traités
internationaux
tweet vindicatif autant qu'ils
responsable nous assistons je crois à la
diplomatie l'agonie de la diplomatie
internationale face à une politique
unilatérale américaine politique un peu
du coup de menton je suis désolé de le
dire sur les réseaux sociaux qui conduit
je crois à une impasse comme
l'illustrent l'exemple de la corée du
nord poursuivant ses programmes
militaires
certains qui est du contexte économique
et social de notre pays
les français n'en sont pas moins
préoccupé des questions internationales
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs des incendies
en amazonie en australie ou de
l'intensification du programme nucléaire
iranien
nos citoyens sont concernés
avec l'élimination du général souleymane
sy par une frappe américaine puis la
riposte de téhéran sur deux bases où
sont stationnés des soldats américains
en irak
la région est plongée dans une escalade
des plus dangereuses la crise iranienne
n'est qu'un des volets d'une situation
générale au proche et moyen-orient
profondément dégradée sur laquelle
finalement nous avons peu de prise
pourtant ge a dit la voix de la france
porte et influer sur le cours des
événements la crise syrienne a montré
que cela n'était plus le cas
dès lors madame la ministre comment
comptez vous ramener la diplomatie
française et européenne dans le jeu et
alors que le président américain vient
de tweets et il ya quelques minutes
avoir l'armé la plus puissante et la
mieux équipée du monde menace d'ailleurs
déjà servi aux nord coréens pour le
résultat que l'on connaît
il est primordial que la france mobilise
ses partenaires européens et les alliés
pour parvenir à la désescalade
comment comptez vous mêmes la ministre
assurer la stabilité régionale de même
que la sécurité des militaires français
encore engagés dans la lutte contre la
haine et la formation des forces
irakiennes qui est l'une des clés de la
stabilisation de l'état irakien
pour